this is a sparkle A310 Eco low profile
single slot GPU and that's powered by
the PCI Express Hole In The Box you get
a GPU and a free- short bracket and
that's it on the card we have a shouty
little fan two display ports and HDMI
2.0b you want to install that low
profile bracket grab some paper towels
and some thermal paines remove this
screw this screw and this we be screw on
the back however that second screw well
that's going to be a bit of a problem
yeah you see this cover it doesn't come
off that means we need to remove the
heat sink and in doing so avoid the
warranty sticker now maybe I'm having a
senior moment here and someone in the
comments will tell me I'm an idiot and
on a completely unrelated note that
there's a simple way to remove the screw
now I didn't see anything in the extens
of documentation so until then let's go
ahead and Des screw the back and pop off
the lid
now we can get to that Critter now time
to clean up the heat lotion add some
fresh processor lube and let's get that
bracket installed all right everything
looks good time for a quick wipe down
with a bit of IPA to destroy the paint
job and there we go now let's cram it in
a thermal note box and poke it with a
Linux
[Music]
stick like AMD Intel's binary drivers
are a hot mess but they have the added
benefit of only being compatible with
one Linux distribution and that last
update for these drivers that was all
the way back in
2023 and you should set your
expectations accordingly and no AR
control is Windows only because reasons
fortunately using the open source
drivers is an absolute Breeze all you
need is a recent kernel and Mesa
version the closest thing to a
monitoring option I was able to find for
the Intel Arc is this two script setup
called Intel Arc monitor now one of the
scripts it just G you basic information
while this other script that offers a
more comprehensive view unfortunately
neither of them include fan control the
lack of fan control for AR gpus under
Linux is a significant drawback for this
card because not only is it a blower
style cooler it's an itsy bitsy blower
style cooler and that means it's really
shouty at idle we have an off on cycle
that will render you clinically insane
after 20 minutes this never stops it is
unending there Is No
Escape and this is what it sounds like
when rendering a video or playing a game
basically anything outside of web
browser
[Music]
lovely av1 encoding worked pretty much
out of the box using the handbrake
nightly flat pack finally found to use
for flat pack very happy about that
encoding a 5-minute clip using av1 SVT
which is using the CPU in this case a
5600 G took a little over 16 minutes in
coding that same clip on the A310 took a
little over
three the A310 worked out of the box
with OBS using the vapy av1 encoder and
more importantly it worked as an av1
add-in card on one of my Nvidia systems
and let's take a look at some sample
footage captured using vapy 264 vapy av1
and just CPU x264 at 1080p with a 6,000
bit rate this is not a quality
comparison but rather like just
demonstration of functionality across
the different encoders and hey it
works add of all the applications I
thought would just work out of the box
blender was going to be the one and I
ended up trying three different versions
of blender and surprisingly it was not
having any of it even after installing
one API and the Intel compute stack
[Music]
nothing welcome to the I would have lost
that bet segment of this video the A310
fired right on andin resolve ND GPU
processing was available using opencl I
was really excited really excited by
this right up until I tried to exit the
cut page which caused toin resolve to
lock right the hell up maybe one
day yes yes I know the A310 isn't
designed for gaming but I wanted to see
how it's stacked up against the
integrated Graphics in my 5600 G these
benchmarks are less about raw
performance and more about B basic
functionality starting out with super
position at 720p low the A310 delivers
78.3 FPS average now in Shadow of the
Tomb Raider at 720p low the A310 manages
a solid
53 and finally in cyber truck at 720p
low the A310 manages
31.4 frames per
second so what do we think of sparkles
A310 Eco you know what it technically
functions as an av1 and coder under
Linux so it has that going for it and if
you're running colel 6.6 plus and a
recent version of Mesa it's going to
work as well as Intel orc Works under
Linux no one's going to run out and buy
this for the integrated Graphics level
gaming performance and even if they did
earplugs would definitely be a
requirement for desktop use that said
people will absolutely buy it to add av1
to their home media servers located in
their basement covered in pillows to
block out the sound
and as you might imagine that's a small
market with the inevitable roll out of
av1 on Twitch and YouTube there's going
to be a lot of people looking to add av1
encoding to their existing streaming
setup on the cheap Sparkle hear me you
got half a product take this card as a
base chop off the video bits find a way
to passively cool it slap on a $75 prize
tag and you know what when av1 rolls out
good luck keeping them in stock also so
get in touch I want some of your other
cards to play with now to keep things
short I glossed over my setup in this
video but you can find the full ride up
on interfacing linux.com and if you have
any questions go ahead and leave those
in the comments and if you get a chance
give me a subscribe and some thumbs so
that glue stick munching YouTube
algorithm will consider recommending
this channel but most importantly get
out there and make something
[Music]
awesome